okay hi everybody and so this video is
based on the patreon comment which I
asked the $10 patrons to suggest a
subject for a video and then I pick
amongst the ones that I feel are the
most interesting now this subject was
given by Jakob Russell and it was the
most voted of all the possible subject
and his question or his his question is
this it says this is probably a big one
but how about communion or the meal /
eating I know you've touched on it but
the whole this is my flesh just makes my
brains world sometimes okay
[Music]
this is Jonathan Petro
welcome to the symbolic world
[Music]
[Applause]
all right so this is something that I
could talk about for ever and so I don't
think I will be able to cover the entire
question of the symbolism of eating and
the symbolism of communion and the
especially the specifics of communion
but I will try to get as much as I can
into this video and if you feel like
there's something missing if you feel
like there like there are some things
that aren't clear go ahead and write it
down in the questions and I will maybe
make a second version a second part of
this video now first first the the idea
of eating now the notion of eating is
extremely important because it has to do
with this idea of knowledge right I've
talked about I've talked about this
notion of of knowing as joining
ourselves with something okay and so
there are several images of that in the
Bible one of the images one of the
images is sexual Union this idea of
joining yourself a man joining himself
with his with his wife that it is a form
of knowledge okay
eating is also a form of knowledge what
it what it is it is just you could say
this way just as a man and his wife are
joined together to become one body okay
so to when you eat you are you are
making body you you are taking the stuff
you know taking food and you are
bringing gathering it into yourself and
it becomes your body okay now that
becomes an image of knowledge that is an
integration Oh
manner in which heaven and earth are
integrated is that the human being man
as microcosm at this central point
gathers the food into himself and it
becomes a it becomes the the potential
out of which his mind his thinking his
spirit can then manifest itself in the
world okay if you watch some of the
videos that I did with my brother Matt's
here he talks about that in those videos
as well and explains it quite well now
in terms of understanding the specifics
of communion there are several things to
understand okay
the first is the notion of eating
together okay
now eating together is a man a manner in
which we participate together in making
a body and so as we sit together and we
eat the same thing together we are if
you will using the same potential in
order to create body we are becoming one
body in that sense we are we are in
communion in that sense that is we are
participating in the making of body okay
and so that that is that is a that is a
good way to understand also a manner in
which the the idea of you know metier in
the video we did he talks about how the
notion of of how a city ready eats
people
and so by eating people right it
integrates all those people into this
one identity and it becomes one thing it
becomes one city in the same manner if
we sit around a table and we are all
eating the same food it's not exactly
the same image but in a in a similar
manner we are we are all joining
ourselves together in in that body okay
and so it is alright so that's that's
let's say the basic idea of why food is
such a a symbol of knowledge and why
it's related
to this notion of eating the fruit of
good and evil which is the fall because
in the notion of eating the fruit of
good and evil we are eating the fruit
the result of the opposition of good and
evil and and by doing that we are
joining ourselves with that and then
especially in the way that it happened
in the story of the fall it's a it's
actually I kind of falling into the body
right not that the body is evil not that
the body is wrong but there is a manner
in which we can kind of fall into the
body where we lose we forget the higher
aspect we forget the the the the aim
which was the Tree of Life we forget
this notion of the you know of our
higher aspects that we kind of fall into
the body and that's why all the images
of the fall are related to this adding
on of body the adding on of the garments
of skin it's kind of this this the world
becomes a hostile and then also
procreation happens after the fall so
all of those all of those images are
images which talk about the same thing
this kind of this kind of descent into
into flesh let's say okay but like I
said it's important to understand that
people have been so confused in thinking
that somehow the body is bad or that
flesh is bad or that or that sexuality
is bad none of those things are bad but
they're bad to the extent into which we
lose ourselves into them right in the to
the extent that we we forget our
humanity and we become become
animalistic we become subject to our own
desires okay so we come we become
subject to our body okay now you can see
that as much with the the belly as with
with sexual desire whereas we can we can
lose ourselves in making body we can we
can become a slave to to the making of
body okay so now that's it that's kind
of out to understand this basic
symbolism of eating first before we
understand the how it plays itself out
afterwards
so now if you take the the the notion of
the notion of eating so eating is the
cause of the fall eating the fruit of
the tree of the knowledge of good and
evil and then so to eating in the end B
is also one of the images of salvation
it's one of the images of of the undoing
or let's say the transformation of the
fall into something higher into
something which actually brings us
closer to God and so now I've talked
about this before one of the aspects of
Christ is that Christ brings everything
together right he brings everything into
itself and so the image that you that
you have in Communion and there's no way
that I can exhaust the symbolism of
communion it's not happening if that's
what you're hoping for in this video
it's not gonna happen
but I can give you some hints I can
because I couldn't do it myself I don't
I don't have the knowledge to exhaust
the symbolism of communion but I can
give you some hints to help you
understand the connection between the
two now so remember Adam and Eve they
eat the fruit of the garden of love eat
the the fruit of the tree of the
knowledge of good and evil they fall
they accumulate flesh right they
accumulate flesh but they also
accumulate death okay that's how it's
presented if you eat the fruit you will
die God gives them these garments of
dead skins and now they accumulate all
these layers and layers and layers of of
death up to the flood okay now what
Christ does is he flips everything
around he's able to bring everything
together in a way that makes her make
your mind explode because he's saying
the manner in which you will now
participate in the life of God is to eat
and he says you're going to eat first of
all the the the
fruit right so the bread and the wine
but that bread and wine is flesh and
blood so think about it think about it
this way Adam and Eve they eat they fall
and then these Falls
this leaves layers of death get to get
added to Adam and Eve and Christ says
you have to eat all that right you have
to you have to you have to be able to
take in death right and it's his death
because he's the one who fills all of
that together so he's saying you have to
eat the the body and drink the blood in
order to fully be able to participate in
this total mystery
which is how Christ fills up the entire
hierarchy from the highest to the lowest
goes down into death and then
consummates the the consummates the fall
he dies he does exactly what Adam and
Eve did he eats the fruit of the
knowledge of good and evil he dies on
the tree and then for we need to eat the
fruit of that in order then for
everything to kind of come together okay
and and I know that this is the the
symbolism of of communion is not easy it
is dumb it is the highest mystery and so
for it to be the highest mystery it
contains everything inside it and and
there is an aspect of scandal to the -
to the to the symbolism of communion
right because you can imagine even at
the beginning of of Christianity the
Romans heard about of the sect of Jews
who were basic who said that they're
eating the blood and body of their of
their Savior and and and it was like
cure these cannibal this cannibal sect
of people who are eating human flesh and
so you can imagine how the Romans
understood what Christianity was but
just like Christ became sin without
sinning
just like Christ you know entered into
the the bottom of death without being
subject to death without being totally
subject he lets he he made himself
subject to death but in the end
conquered death so to this notion of
eating the breadth of the body and blood
we're eating bread and wine we're not
right we're not literally ripping
ripping pieces of flesh off off a human
body and so it's a met but it's real at
the same time and so the notion of
saying that it's real but it's also
something which transcends the
categories right which joins them all
together is able to for us to understand
how the scandal is part of this totality
but we also transcend the scandal by by
by eating bread and and drinking wine
okay I hope this is this is making sense
to you because it's it's not an easy
it's not a totally easy subject to
understand obviously that's why we say
it's mystery but there's also like I
said this other aspect which is this
notion of the communion table the altar
being also a table in which we enter
into communion with God okay so the
image that we have in the Orthodox
Church we we use this image of the
hospitality of Abraham and in the
hospitality of Abraham these three
angels appeared to to Abraham and
Abraham serve them food and it has
become an image of the Trinity those
three angels have become for Christians
an image of the Trinity and so we have
this image by Andrew Rublev of the three
angels who are symbolizing for us the
Trinity and then there's this open space
at the table in front of us which is
that we now come and enter into to
communion and the image of the communion
is that we come to share a meal with
with with the Trinity okay obviously
it's a it's an imagistic form but then
the commune
Union table in the church becomes this
entering into the life of God by by by
eating the flesh of the of the logos we
commune with the logos just like we have
the same body as God we have we
participate in God's body that is the
body of Christ that is the church okay
all the whole this imagery is completely
coherent even though on on a on a purely
rationalistic side it might be difficult
for people to understand but the the V
and it's not just that it's important to
understand it's not just a mental game
it's not just abstractions but by by
actually eating the the taking communion
physically taking communion we have to
do it in a physical sense in order to
fully enter into that relationship in
order for the communion to not just be a
mental game not just be something that
we think of in our own mind but to
actually come together around the
communion table eat the same bread drink
the same wine participate in this
sacrament all together and at the same
time knowing that participating in this
sacrament is entering into what
transcends it right entering into the
life of God that is the whole notion of
what communion is of what liturgy is and
of what the Orthodox notion of
participation in God and participation
in the life of God is all about so I
think that that is really the the basic
idea of communion now in terms of why
flesh and blood
why bread and wine I've talked about
this a little bit obviously once again I
cannot I cannot exhaust the symbolism
you would need to read the whole Bible
to kind of get a sense of all those
places but we need to understand that
the bay
the category so you have bread which is
a staple bread which is a you know it's
it's the basic food of of life and it's
also solid okay so you have this notion
of a solid food that you eat then
there's wine which is first of all
liquid okay so it is it is an image of
change and image of of the of kind of a
bit of a chaotic influence but then wine
as well which is a form of fermentation
so fermented element you know the the
the fermentation is basically a form of
death and so wine is a kind of turning
of death against against itself and then
when you drink wine you also are
inebriated you you you are in a state of
flux here again for those who have read
Mateusz book you will you will
understand what it is that I'm talking
about and so you have bread you have
wine which is those these two basic
categories you could say space and time
right that are part of communion but
then then they're taken up to
transformed into something which is both
at the same time you know higher but
also at the same time it kind of scandal
which is the eating of flesh which is
akin to bread which is in our body
it's our solid it's our solid state it's
our it's our you know it's it's the
basic it's a it's our basic
understanding of what the body is and
then blood which is once again the
liquid free-flowing aspect of ourselves
at the same time in the tradition of the
sacrifice you really had this idea of
blood representing let's say the more
spiritual aspect in the Bible it says
that blood is the soul of the body and
so this idea that blood represents the
kind of more spiritual aspect and then
the the body represents the more
physical you know the more in
incarnate aspect and then the way there
was this weird exchange where when they
would sacrifice an animal they would
they would sprinkle the blood down right
sprinkle it on to the horns of the altar
and then also they would pour it out on
the ground so it was this kind of this
thing coming down to the ground but at
the same time they would offer up the
flesh to to God and so God would eat the
flesh and then you know acquire body
which was also our prayers which was
also our communion which was also the
coming together of the people which
would become the body which was offered
up to God for God to - - to be manifest
themselves in your life and in your and
in the life of the of the the people of
Israel that's that's one of the one of
the ways to kind of understand ancient
sacrifice now in communion we have once
again it's like mind-blowing thing where
we consume both the bread and the blood
and and the wine we consume both the
flesh and the blood which is absolutely
unheard of there's nowhere in the Old
Testament that the priests or anybody
would consume the blood of the of the
sacrifice but they would eat the meat of
the sacrifice so they would burn they
would cook the meat and then they would
they would eat the meat of the sacrifice
and the smoke would go up we go up to
God but they would also participate in
eating the meat but no one would ever
eat the blood and so for Christians to
eat the meat that eat the flesh and also
drink the blood is it has to do again
with this notion that Christ fills up
the whole thing
contains the whole mystery right and in
him is both the highest and the lowest
so both the thing
thing that comes down all the way down
and drips down into the into into the
bottom but the thing that's from down
that from below and goes who is raised
up into the highest in Christ contains
those two things together and so that is
that is one of the that is a hint let's
say to help you understand why it is
those elements which are brought
together in communion like I said I'm
not exhausting this and and and there's
much more to it that I could encompass
in a video but hopefully this will give
give all of you a little sense of why
eating is so important why how it's
related to knowledge and also how it is
how it comes together in communion and
maybe one last little thing that I can
mansion is that in eating there is also
two aspects in order to if you want to
understand eating can also help us to
understand sexuality because sexuality
and eating are very close together if
you look at the stories in the Bible and
in other stories as well in other
traditions you'll see how closely
related they are even in the in the fall
but there are there are two aspects to
eating itself you know and so eating has
a nutritional aspect okay that's you
could say there are three parts let's
say eating has a nutritional aspect
which is we're building body where you
were eating in order to be able to
continue living as human beings there's
an aspect of eating which is which
brings us pleasure okay and then there's
a third aspect of eating which is when
we eat together it creates this
communion it could it creates this
community where we eat together and we
participate in the same body okay and
and sexuality has the same aspects that
is there is an aspect of sexuality which
is to to propagate the human race okay
and so so it is therefore the humanity
to continue to exist just like food is
for you to continue to exist there's an
aspect of it which is
which brings pleasure and there's an
aspect of it of it which is on a larger
scale which is communion communion with
the person with whom you're having a
sexual relationship but also building
community by creating family and and
these families clump together and create
larger community okay and so in the
Christian understanding of a vote eating
and sexuality those all of those
elements have to come together have to
be united together somehow and it
doesn't mean that that that it doesn't
mean that you can't you can't have an
ice cream cone right and it doesn't mean
that you you have to only eat things
that are just so healthy for you that
you know but but it means that there has
to be a pattern where all those things
come together where where in your life
you are eating to to to to to build your
body you're eating to also to to
encourage Communion and you're also
enjoying what you're eating okay and
it's the same with sexuality so that's
why in Christianity the notion of
marriage is so important one of the
reasons why it's so important because in
marriage you have that pattern where all
those three elements of sexuality are
gathered together into into something
into a symbol right into the whole this
whole idea of what I talk about when I
talk about symbolic relationship that is
they're brought together so that their
essence appears in all these elements
coming together so we we can see what
eating is and then it can help us to
understand communion because the
communion with God has also those let's
say those three elements think it
together okay everybody so if you
haven't gotten Mateusz book you should
get my to his book because there's a lot
of stuff that i'm gonna be talking about
in the in the next videos that are going
to relate to his book there are a lot of
things happening I'm going I'm starting
I've already started a monthly Q&A with
with patrons so you can find that find
the
information on patreon I'm also working
on a website right now reading lists all
of that is happening as I make this
video and so look forward to seeing that
hopefully as soon as possible
turns out making a website is more
complicated if you want it in a certain
way so but it's happening there's also
my next video curled cultural
interpretation is going to be called
something like Batman no it's gonna be
called something like Adam and Eve and
Batman and I just to show